what is joe biden going to keep those
policies going i don't know we don't
know he hasn't said
i kind of feel like he's uh he wouldn't
do that
like you mentioned before you know he's
going to try and differentiate himself
from the trump administration
so already you know we had this uh this
trump put in this executive order about
keeping china out chinese made you know
equipment out of the
u.s u.s electrical grid and then joe
biden's like we're going to freeze that
rule
so it's no longer in effect and review
it and i'm like if you want to review
the rule wouldn't you
leave the the restrictions in place why
would joe biden just say okay yeah
trying to come back into the u.s
electrical grid
i think it's a little unclear what
happened and like he could potentially
be using that
for his advantage but there was sort of
a blanket freeze on a lot of last minute
uh
right policies by trump which i think is
in general
pretty common for an incoming president
to do
uh and the issue is with biden like so
that could be
i'm so fine he's he's frozen those he
reviews him the issue with the binding
administration is it comes under this
cloud of
uh biden personally and a lot of the
people he's appointed to his cabinet
they're past
failures with china policy uh scandals
like
hunter biden putting this cloud overbite
and gives him the appearance
of like you should not be questioning if
the us
president is really going to condemn gem
genocide yeah and we are
and the other thing too is i think it's
fascinating how they say that you know
donald trump was the manchurian
candidate for russia or whatever that he
was a russian asset he was a puppeter or
you know and all that stuff and now we
actually have the circumstance where
you know we're six weeks out and joe
biden has not
given an address to a joint session of
congress
you'd have to go back to jimmy carter in
1977 for the for the last time it took
this long now he was into april so maybe
joe biden will
still beat jimmy carter and give some
kind of speech but he's not given a
press conference
in in in in the entirety of his his six
weeks so
already things seem to be a bit
unprecedented and then we had that
scenario where he was giving
uh he was talking to the democratic
caucus and then he says i'll take
questions
the camera shuts off the feed ends
now many people on the right said as
soon as joe biden offered to take
questions they turned the camera off and
the response from the journalists was
he took the questions off camera you're
misunderstanding you're confused and my
response is
why why was he doing the session live
and then took the cam the questions off
camera that's a ridiculous excuse
because either way the american people
deserve to see
what our politicians are asking the
president and what he is saying to them
when i saw that you know i was sitting
at jack murphy and he was jack was just
like
manchurian candidate like not literally
just like kind of joking like
what's going on to where the president
of the united states
isn't doing press conferences isn't
giving a joint uh
an address to the joint session of
congress and then he can't even answer
questions on a live stream
who is he what's he doing and then you
tie that into the hunter biden stuff
flying his son an air force to china for
that private equity deal
and then am i supposed to trust this
president as our best interest
at heart as we're entering either
the uh strass howe generational theory
winter
or thucydides trap there there's
academics who are
telling us we're in for some serious
trouble and we're looking at genocide
and we're looking at organ harvesting
and we're looking at hong kong falling
now we're looking at taiwan
it looks like china is getting away with
every single
thing they've done wrong and we're doing
nothing about it but say what maybe some
sanctions here and there
well i think that 2020 was actually a
banner year for the chinese communist
party it didn't start out that way it
looked like the world was going to turn
against them after the coronavirus it's
amazing
they turned they turned out that
completely around and
now they're using that as propaganda for
like how well that their system is doing
compared to everybody else
more reason to cooperate with china and
i think that like
one the one thing the biden
administration recently came out with
their interim national security policy
and reading that i was actually pretty
worried about how they were going to
like deal with china because it seemed
to kind of revert back to like an obama
administration era of like the whole
thing that we were talking about before
about like we need to cooperate still
um the trump administration specifically
in their national security policy
called out the chinese communist party
and said you know it's a
marxist-leninist organization
said we we are going to treat this the
way that the chinese communist party
treats this which is
which they said that they are in a great
power competition with the us
so fine we acknowledge that you know
china says that we're in a great power
competition with them
and the buying administration seems to
have gone back to
that like oh you know we disagree we're
economic rivals we're competitors but
we can work together on some things and
then the other part of the national
security policy that i found kind of
a little bit alarming is the fact that
they seem to want to blur the line
between
foreign policy and domestic policy like
there's a specific part where they talk
about
how you know we can't just have foreign
policy and domestic policy be separate
we have to
you know if we really want to have
effective foreign policy we have to fix
our own internal problems
so then that brought up like systemic
racism and equity and all this stuff
so it seems like if that's what they
want to focus on
they're going to be too focused on like
internal things and
this ideological battle and not focused
enough on
the genuine threat that the chinese
communist party is which is strange
because
the executive branch their main thing is
to deal with foreign policy
domestic policy is supposed to be the
legislative
branch well here we are with uh
every single uh line item of china
violating some kind of human rights
civil rights
stealing destroying we're buying back
around technology that was stolen from
us and then
cheaply knocked off and built by slaves
built by slaves and they just keep doing
it and we just keep
you know doting along accepting it i
will say i posted a meme though that was
that was uh
made everybody angry it was on i think
was on the 20th i said
uh the peaceful transition of power from
the previous administration
to the new administration is complete
and it was a picture of vladimir putin
and then
xi jinping and i was like there you go
whatever your political ideology is you
know the left viewed trump as this like
beholden guy to russia but russia wasn't
really doing all that much
i mean sure there's conflict over
pipelines and you know
ukraine and things like that syria
perhaps
but what's happening with china really
does seem to be
it could be theoretically the catalyst
for some very serious major war
if we're not already in the peak of it
which is information war
but you know i i that's why i have to
wonder about the things we see in
america in the culture war
is it really in the best interest of
either america or china to engage a hot
war with missiles and bullets
probably not it never is for anybody
it's very expensive and then you have to
hope you're going to win
but information warts it's more syrup
tissues it's aversive
so i wonder you know to what extent
china is
influencing our social media and
manipulating us much the way they
accused
the russians of doing it i don't know if
you guys have seen anything that would
suggest
those kind of operations i think it's a
little different actually what china has
really been manipulating very
successfully is in american elites
and it's almost like they don't have to
do the kind of awkward like twitter
thing right where they're like
having dummy accounts on twitter and
trying to influence people on facebook
like the chinese tommy's probably much
better at this than i mean russia
they just tweeted out right like the the
members of the chinese communist party
are like tweeting really offensive
things like
the picture of the australian soldier or
whatever they just it's it's
it's uh reminds him that simpson
simpson's a bit i don't know if you guys
have ever seen the episode
where bart joins a boy band that's
subliminally trying to get people to
join the navy
and the art the navy recruiter tells
lisa we
we recruit by the subliminal the liminal
and the super liminal
and lisa goes super liminal and he goes
yeah and he opens the window and goes
hey you
join the navy and then lenny and carl
are like okay
so so that's kind of what i feel like
when i see these like high rank you know
these like
you know uh officials in the communist
party or like chinese government
officials
blue check mark on twitter tweeting some
ridiculous absurd conspiracy theory
about the election or the president and
it's allowed they're allowed they're
allowed to do it i'm like there it is
that's
that's the super liminal right in your
face we're lying and we can do whatever
we want we don't need bots
i well so a good example of this is um
how china manipulates language man i'm
going to pass that
off to you in just a second but like
just like one example of how chinese
propaganda seeps
into uh american discourse is going back
to the biden town hall
how he was talking about how john you
know china had the century of
humiliation they need they
need to have the strong centralized core
that's communist party propaganda that's
being parroted
by president by the president and that's
not like
that's not saying he's not unique in
that it's because the communist party is
very good at
uh taking language and changing the
meaning of it
yeah i mean i think it's it's not just
just that which i get to in a minute but
the
the you'll circle back to that
i'm not yeah attention the overall idea
is like you know you tim you talk about
the
the overt stuff uh the super liminal
we're seeing on twitter which is the
propaganda from the chinese foreign
minister but the
the real way that we're seeing that
influence is actually
through what's called elite capture uh
which is
the chinese communist party convincing
influential
people around the world including
american politicians
american business leaders american
academics these are the
and and journalists these are the
thought leaders in american society
and the communist party is is
influencing them
and now these groups the
the politicians the business leaders the
media
are all the cheerleaders for the
communist party
and it may not be so obvious that
they're saying rah-rah-rah
communism because they're not saying it
that way what they're saying is like
well
look at uh you know china has lifted
millions of people out of poverty
uh you know china uh you know china is a
competitor but we need to work with them
and they've gotten people to
to parrot these lines which on the
surface seem reasonable
but actually they're exactly what the
communist party wants and they do that
through a variety of influence campaigns
to get these people on their side the
challenge is
like when we hear um you know
whether it's you know bernie sanders
saying oh you know
but you know china i don't like
authoritarianism but china has
lifted 700 million people out of poverty
right
well it it's that's the propaganda line
that's making you think well maybe they
do have some elements to their system
network is look how many people they've
lifted out of poverty
and it is true that since 1978
hundreds of millions of people in china
have
gotten out of poverty but it's not the
communist party that
lifted them out of poverty it was the
communist party that
put them in poverty in the first place
oh yeah right but then how did they get
out of poverty it wasn't government
policy was it was actually
the reform and opening up the gaiga
kaifung started by deng xiaoping in 78
and these policies gradually took the
boot off of people's necks
so that they could you know have
businesses and and start their own
uh enterprises in the free market and
people lifted themselves out of poverty
and
investment it's kind of like when it's
you know in the summer and it's really
hot
and you're really sweaty so you go under
the blanket for a few seconds
and then you get really hot when you
take the blanket off it feels really
cool and refreshing
for a little bit yeah so so maybe what
we should do in the us
is have this uh extended lockdown where
we destroy
everyone's business for maybe a year and
then
after about you know a two years because
you know biden saying
next year is normal then we can be like
look at all of the people the biden
administration has lifted out of poverty
he's
tremendously starting with the bankers
yes which i mean oh they came in real
quick to save those folks
uh and you know i mean there's nothing
i'm not saying there's anything you know
necessarily wrong about trying to keep
the stock market from having a complete
crash
but uh definitely
uh there are some shortcomings in terms
of the overall response
but anyways to to get to the point about
like
uh you've got you've got the communist
party getting people to repeat these
lines
but the problem is you know when when
you hear this you know
lifting millions of people out of
poverty you also have to realize
like that china now says for example uh
you know being out of poverty is a human
right
right so that it's the top human rights
it's the main sounds like
it's the main human right and and so a
lot of people on the surface they think
oh
well like yeah like like it's so bad to
be in this abject poverty like maybe
maybe it is a human right to
to have money and you know you can agree
or disagree on that but that's not the
point
the point is that now you know you've
added
uh the communist party has added
economic prosperity
as a human right and they've gotten a
lot of people to kind of go along with
it but what you're not seeing is that
they've
they haven't just added on to the
meaning of human rights they've actually
changed the meaning
because china is using that
instead of giving people the human
rights that we consider human rights the
life the rights to life
liberty in the pursuit of happiness you
don't have the right to life when you
can be sent to
a concentration camp or killed for your
organs
or welded into your apartment so you can
die yeah i mean
and that's like the the fact that that's
happening
in china as part of their coveted
response shows a complete disregard
for human rights a complete disregard
for individual liberty liberties
uh but you got a macbook yeah well i
mean
well and then china says ah but we
stopped kovit yeah we had to weld people
in their
homes but we stopped because that video
which isn't true
the giant bar they like wedged between
the door and the wall so the door can't
be opened
there's one of like a woman being
dragged into like this box on a pickup
truck screaming the whole time
yeah well i think the other thing with
the the the
elite capture is like you one thing that
it's important to
notice and i think we'll see more and
more of this is
you'll see people saying we need to
reengage with china there was a foreign
affairs magazine
article by this guy named ryan haas that
was basically
saying you know china alarmism doesn't
help anyone like that was basically the
title sounds like mark cuban right yeah
like yeah this whole idea that like oh
we can't you know that mark cuban
definitely the whole like china's a
customer so we can't really critic i
don't want to criticize them because
they're a customer
but like this whole idea uh that like we
need to like re-engage like oh
the trump administration was wrong too
like you know they made the conflict
worse when really it was
really the chinese communist party but
the whole idea is that we need to now
like we need to soften our stance to
china china is not so bad the communist
party is not so bad
you know yeah i mean it's just a little
genocide you want to talk about that
atrocious
uh economist article oh yeah there was
an article on the economist after
the whole um genocide thing with the
trump administration and they said
okay uh the canadian parliament was
voting that was genocide and the
economist ran this article
basically being like is it really
genocide though
because you know when people even though
the un definition of genocide includes
trying to eliminate a people
including by preventing births
and sterilization and things that are
happening to the uyghurs in china like
that is part of the un convention on
genocide
like that is def defined as genocide the
economist was like
but most people think of genocide as
being mass murder so if it's not to that
point yet
and we use the word genocide aren't we
kind of you know
isn't that worse for you know future
genocides that like
now cheapen the word specifically said
they're not slaughtering them
as they're being butchered their own
well no the organ harvesting is just
win-win mutual cooperation cooperation
on the communist party's terms between
the uyghurs and the don't and the organ
recipients
yes that's cooperative there's an
exchange going on so it's cooperation
as long as two parties are willing in
this it doesn't matter
yeah if someone else isn't i mean it's
it's a democracy so it's for the good of
the majority yes the
what do they say the people's
dictatorships well if they don't view
the uyghurs as people then there's no
as humans there's no human rights
violation right oh no the the 56 ethnic
minorities of china are very happy
every year they have a wonderful new
year's show where they they bring them
all out and have a little dance number
or they'll give the bbc a guided tour of
these alleged
concentration camps and they're singing
and getting
you know job skills and they're dancing
for the camera
with big bruises over their eyes like
it's very
it is but it's very hard for foreigners
to see what's actually happening in
china
i think you have to break it down yeah
like like you can't like you just don't
get access as a foreigner
like the the last time i was in mainland
uh which was which was
more than 15 years ago it's you know uh
it wasn't even so closed off but at the
time like you know
they wanted foreigners to be in certain
parts of the big cities
uh and they wanted you to be on on tours
and they didn't want you to go outside
of that and if they did and if you did
go outside of that
the authorities might try to like you
know get you to go back to your hotel
uh and now it's even more restrictive uh
where
like they're basically they keep
journalists out of going to like
villages where controversial things are
going on
they ki you know essentially a foreign
reporter can't possibly get into better
xinjiang anymore
so it's it's just like like the people
who are going to china these
the politicians the business people the
academics
they're going to the cities they're
getting on these high-speed rails
they're staying in the five-star hotels
they're eating at nice restaurants and
this is the part of china they see
and so they have a very skewed
view of what china is
okay well so here's here's a bit of
optimism for you you're saying you're
pessimistic
um yeah that's absolutely right it's
hard for foreigners to know what's
happening in china
the reason i started china and censored
in 2012 was because
everything we've talked about tonight is
really not new it's been going on
for decades i started the show because
americans didn't know about americans
weren't talking about this and just
thought china was like oh you know
developing country it's a democracy
right so now you trust it
there's a president but now you talk
about this pew
research uh and the it's totally
shifted people are talking about the
chinese communist party in a way they
were not
yeah even eight years ago even five
years ago it's interesting the president
think because i have had multiple
conversations with
friends of mine who were like didn't
know that china didn't have democracy
because the
it's called he called them president xi
jinping even though the word in chinese
is not president it is chairman chairman
of the state right so
like the word they use in chinese to
talk about xi jinping there's a
different word that they use for
president
that they used to talk about biden or
you know like it's like
the word is zongtong why do we call them
presidents propaganda because
they started translating in the 80s they
started translating
president that drew c which is chairman
as
president like officially the official
translation in china
in china and so manipulation yeah so
that that's the
they twist the language thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you